bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero
Emmanuel macron realiza esta semana una
visita a Washington de Gran importancia
en un momento en el que las relaciones
entre Francia y Estados Unidos están en
horas bajas cuestiones como el papel de
Estados Unidos en la Guerra de Ucrania
sus beneficios en la crisis energética o
los subsidios multimillonarios a la
transición verde han alejado a los
socios de la Unión Europea y
concretamente a París de un Aliado
tradicional como lo es Estados Unidos
por este motivo en France 24 repasamos
las relaciones diplomáticas a lo largo
de la historia entre Francia y Estados
Unidos
unas relaciones que datan desde el mismo
origen de Estados Unidos como nación ya
que Francia fue uno de los mayores
aliados de los colonos para conseguir la
independencia frente a Reino Unido un
acontecimiento que forjó una relación
relativamente cordial a lo largo del
siglo 19 y que incluso llegó a que
durante el mandato de Napoleón Bonaparte
Francia vendiera el territorio de la
Luisiana francesa por 23 millones de
dólares algo que permitió a Estados
Unidos doblar su tamaño
algunos ejemplos de esta relación es que
nunca estuvieron en guerra o el regalo
de Francia en 1886 a Estados Unidos de
la Estatua de la Libertad uno de sus
mayores símbolos acercamientos que los
llevaron a ser aliados con intereses
comunes con la llegada del siglo XX
Especialmente cuando en 1914 Europa
entró en conflicto ya que aunque Estados
Unidos se mantuvo neutral al comienzo en
1917 entró en la guerra para defender
los intereses de Reino Unido y Francia
frente a Alemania y el Imperio
austrohúngaro una ayuda que resultó
fundamental para obtener la victoria
este apoyo convirtió al expresidente
Wood Road Wilson en una figura muy
popular en Francia Aunque Durante los
acuerdos de paz las posiciones de
Estados Unidos y Francia estuvieron
realmente opuestas ya que París exigió
una dureza mayor contra Alemania que
obligará a esta nación a pagar todos los
gastos de la guerra y la debilitará a
futuro especialmente por el temor que
tenía Francia ante otra invasión sin
embargo esto fomento el ascenso del
nazismo años después durante el periodo
de entreguerras Estados Unidos se
encargó de proporcionar armas a Francia
ante el crecimiento de La amenaza de la
Alemania nazi pero esta ayuda llegó
tarde iniciada la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Francia colapsó ante el avance alemán en
junio de 1940 para ese momento Estados
Unidos no formaba parte de la contienda
mundial Pero en cuanto entró en ella en
1941 fue parte activa en la lucha contra
el nazismo en Europa y contra la Francia
de vichy un régimen títere de Berlín de
hecho Estados Unidos ayudó a los
miembros de la Francia libre a retomar
su país en 1944 tras el desembarco de
normandía y volvió a ser fundamental
para Francia y Reino Unido en la
victoria contra la Alemania nazi en 1945
además después de la contienda Estados
Unidos convirtió a Francia en la segunda
nación más beneficiada por el Plan
Marshall para su reconstrucción se
estima que Washington brindó entre
créditos y subvenciones casi 5.000
millones de dólares de la época de los
cuales 2.300 millones se invirtieron a
fondo perdido
Francia pasó así a formar parte del
bloque occidental durante la Guerra Fría
las dos naciones se posicionaron como
aliadas frente a la unión soviética y
fueron miembros fundadores de
organizaciones como la otan Aunque
dentro de esta Alianza Estados Unidos
mantuvo muchas discrepancias con
respecto al papel de Francia con sus
colonias e incluso se desató una crisis
en 1956 cuando Reino Unido Francia e
Israel invadieron Egipto tras la
nacionalización egipcia del canal de
suez y Estados Unidos obligó a estos
tres países a frenar sus ataques estos
desencuentros aumentaron todavía más
tras la llegada al poder de sal de golf
quien quiso desarrollar un programa
nuclear propio que no contaba con el
visto bueno de Washington de Gol se
mostró contrario al poder predominante
de Estados Unidos en occidente en su
intento de crear una fuerza defensiva
independiente de golf sacó del mando
militar la otan a Francia y expulsó a
las tropas de la alianza de su país una
situación que tensó las relaciones con
Estados Unidos Aunque finalmente nunca
se produjo la salida definitiva de
Francia de la organización militar
durante las tres décadas siguientes en
la relación entre los dos países mejoró
Aunque mostró a una Francia cada vez más
interesada en liderar el proyecto de la
Unión Europea junto con Alemania
las tensiones no volvieron hasta el año
2003 cuando el entonces presidente
francés jacks rechazó enviar tropas a la
guerra de Irak iniciada por George Bush
esta cuestión desató en Estados Unidos
una campaña de boicot a productos
franceses que se extrapoló incluso a las
papas fritas ya que los estadounidenses
pasaron de llamarlas French fries papas
francesas a freedom price papas de la
libertad y aunque en líneas generales
los dos países han compartido objetivos
como la lucha contra el terrorismo en
los últimos años la alianza se ha vuelto
a enrarecer por diversos motivos como el
deterioro de la relación del
expresidente Donald Trump y el
mandatario francés Emmanuel macron por
desencuentros como la salida de Estados
Unidos del acuerdo de París
Francia es una gran defensora de la
independencia económica y militar de
Europa con respecto a Estados Unidos por
ello macron promueve desde hace años
crear el ejército europeo y es un
profundo crítico del subsidio verde a
empresas de
369.000 millones de dólares lanzado por
joeyden una estrategia que desde Europa
afirman que perjudica a sus productos y
que sumado a los altos precios del
combustible estadounidense puede
desembocar en una guerra comercial tras
atlántica con esto concluimos Gracias
por compartir y comentar esas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]